[Applause]
and finally new rule here in the season
of giving can we at least agree that
giving is good I bring this up because
one of the more mind-blowing stories of
this year was about the internet
celebrity Mr Beast and how he was always
getting raked over the coals for a
series of charitable Endeavors now if
you don't know Mr Beast is the most
successful YouTuber ever with over 38
billion views feel old
now anyway he takes some of the money
made from 38 billion views and plows it
back into doing things like this year
partnering with a group of doctors to
provide cataract surgery for a thousand
blind people that restored their
eyesight cool huh
wrong he filmed their Overjoyed
reactions which to many made him a
performative altruist a Washington Post
reporter tweeted what truly needs curing
is society's view of disabled people and
BuzzFeed agreed Mr Beast seems to regard
disability as something that needs to be
solved okay disability is something that
needs to be
soled and what truly needs curing Is
Blindness here's how I know
this the newly cited people are cheering
not booing because Mr Beast whoever the
that
is just cured them and you didn't do
you know the expression or go
blind you didn't
either I tell you I I don't get the woke
they love nothing more than being a
victim except when they really are one
and then they tell you I am not go
yourself
get get this uh last month Mr Beast in
another dick
move funded the construction of a
hundred Wells across five countries in
Africa to provide clean drinking water
to half a million people good thing
right
no not good
bad the founder of a charity called face
Africa called it kind of frustrating
that overnight this person comes along
who happens to be a white male figure
with a huge platform and all of a sudden
he gets all of the
attention yes
but but you know what else is
frustrating dying of
thirst Mr Beast how dare he come in and
Bogart digging the wells
that's so white guy always taking fresh
water and shoving it down our
throats oh another thing this
did in
Africa was pay for the rebuilding of an
African orphanage which the director of
The Hope and homes for children charity
called it a classic case of white
saviorism so true ask any orphan to name
the worst part of their life show
offs
please please we should be celebrating
having dead parents hey it didn't hurt
Batman H H how did we get to this weird
place telling people who are actually
out in the world making a positive
difference you're the problem
yeah um quick question who the are
you
and and uh this isn't only the media and
the people on Twitter who exist to
always finding something he just did it
for the clicks or for the wrong reason
or you should have done more or sooner
whatever you suck signed
x no no no
no th this is this is also the National
Institutes of Health which last year
proposed to amend their mission
statement to exclude the word disability
saying it quote could be interpreted as
perpetuating ableist beliefs that
disabled people are flawed and need to
be
fixed let me take this moment to go on
record folks if if I am ever struck
blind or deaf or paralyzed don't praise
me fix
me
don't don't don't sit around talking
about how much I'm just as good as you
fix me do something use AI invent
something steal body parts from a pet
cemetery steal stem cells from frog
whatever it takes Jean sequencing
robotic eyeballs harvesting clones
inject me with hamster platelets grow a
new gallbladder from impossible meat
just do
something and if I catch on fire you
also have my absolute permission to piss
on my
ass you know there's there's so much
much faking this time of year between
the presents you don't want to buy and
the presents you didn't want to get and
the Goodwill toward men that last until
January
2nd I just don't have room for and
disability is awesome it's not awesome
and it's not a political affiliation
that's the problem we turn everything
into a political identity category
you're DEA that's your identity don't
mess up a good thing by
hearing
when uh Adell lost weight she was
excoriated for betrayal to to who she
betrayed the
unhealthy the woke have even turned the
homeless into a political identity group
as opposed to liberals old school
liberals who just want to get them off
the street which now is seen as kind of
judgy like
don't disturb them in their natural
habitat they're they're just they're
just living their best life under the
bridge the woke think the number one job
is to protect homeless people from
stigma I think the number one job is to
protect them from
rain
speaking of which when I did the Ice
Bucket Challenge back in 2014 I thought
I was helping the cause of funding
research to cure ALS wrong
again and opad in Time Magazine said the
ice bucket challenge even seems to be
suggesting that being cold wet and
uncomfortable is preferable to fighting
Al it was suggesting no such thing what
is wrong with this country that so many
people can't be happy for anything for
even a second ice bucket challenge
America is more ready for the can you
on something good challenge and yes
we're up to
it